bitcoin miners down in texas they proved
all the haters wrong this past saturday
there's been a massive heat wave and all
of that is putting a lot of pressure on
citizens of texas well what we saw was
the rockdale texas facility they shut
off all their miners at 8 a.m on
saturday and what that allowed for them
to do was divert that energy they would
have been consuming back onto the grid
they kept their miners off until 10 p.m
on saturday night
that is a perfect example of how bitcoin
miners can help stabilize the energy
grid now of course these bitcoin miners
they are going to look to make a profit
except for when the grid needs to be
stabilized so when they shut off those
bitcoin miners in rockdale texas were
able to help stabilize 13 000 households
with energy that could allow them to
cool during the extreme heat
once the heat dissipates they'll turn
the machines back on and they'll
continue to make a profit that is until
the energy grid needs to be stabilized
next time the esg movement and plenty of
critics they continue to yell and scream
about bitcoin mining they say that it
consumes too much energy and that it's
not good for the environment but what we
are watching is time and time again
bitcoin miners are able to stabilize
these energy grids and i think that
they're actually going to become an
essential part of local economies
building out energy grids if bitcoin
miners can turn on and turn off their
machines in very short periods of time
it allows for energy grids that produce
too much energy to actually monetize it
but to then pull that energy back and
support their citizens when they need it
most
bitcoin mining is not only good for the
energy grid but it's also not nearly as
destructive for the environment as the
esg critics would make you think
at the end of the day bitcoin mining is
the ultimate test of independent
thinking you can buy into the public
narrative you can simply read headlines
or you can go do the work for yourself
the more you learn about bitcoin mining
its energy consumption and its ability
to stabilize energy grids the more it
becomes obvious bitcoin mining is here
to stay but bitcoin mining is also going
to become an essential part of the
energy infrastructure built in the
united states of america